one thing I'm curious about as your
credit has been on the platform so long
because obviously sometimes you you do
cover drama how is it sometimes let's
say if like drama happens with someone
that maybe you have connections to or
maybe you're like close ties to or maybe
even you know maybe sometimes you're
like am I is it okay if I talk about
this like it's you know like how do you
how do you handle that thing that I've
always I've always like stayed away from
ever talking about [ __ ] publicly about
any even if there's drama happening I
think all three of us yeah because I'm
just like I'm like what if this like
somehow like they bounce back and they
remember me being an [ __ ] and I'm the
piece of [ __ ] who said something even
though it was totally you know what I
mean I'm like always like I don't know
how do you like how do you deal with
that I don't know it's all impulsive
like I don't really give a lot of
thought like if it's like some goofy
drama I'll usually just be like this is
why it's goofy this is Goofy this is
what they're doing and this is what
happened yeah I never really think like
if there's any like angle that could
have been worked or something like that
I also feel like with the way you
address a lot of that kind of stuff in
your videos you're very articular with
the first first of all but I feel you're
addiction yeah
they're very articulate but like I feel
in a lot of ways you're also you I don't
know if you're trying to consciously do
this but I feel in a lot of ways you're
very like neutral and fair about the
situation like you kind of just like say
it how it is and like these are the
facts this is what's happening here's
like my tiny little two cents and then
that's it kind of thing right you don't
really like you know pick a side
blatantly usually unless it's something
that I like have a very strong opinion
of right like yeah for example like the
pink sauce lady she was on top
if you were on the other side then I
think everyone would have been like what
the [ __ ] yeah like there are times where
I'll pick a side like yeah of course
this from reading or learning about all
this but you didn't know the pink Source
lady person
[Music]
but I feel if it's with Like You Know
Drama concerning like a fellow content
creator for example oh someone I know
yeah like someone you know I feel you're
very good at kind of being neutral about
it yeah I mean [ __ ] twitch every week
pretty much I'll be out of forensics
yeah yeah there's not a whole lot left
everyone's always getting tossed into
something yeah is there even any point
covering it is it like this is not new
only if it's I usually only cover it if
it's entertaining or if it's something
that I'm like feeling strongly about
like it's like a serious situation yeah
I have a pretty strong opinion on what's
going on here I'll cover it but then
other times where if it's like
without getting like too specific like
someone going through like a mental
health episode yeah broadcasting it I'm
not gonna talk about that yeah but I
feel what's good is that you have like
such a big variety of content that you
don't need to like pressure yourself oh
yeah to make content about drama or
stuff like that yeah yeah because I mean
I mean there are like so many like
commentary drama channels and YouTube
now like I swear people there's like
entire channels which is the genre is
let's like take this one tweet and like
make a [ __ ] video about it you know
well I've definitely done that I've seen
some dog [ __ ]
I couldn't help it was it a chef Rogan
won that one time oh that was that one
what was that one the one Seth Rogen was
like why are you complaining about your
car being broken yeah it was it opens
all the time Casey neistat made a tweet
he's like a [ __ ] car got broken into
ages I hate La Seth Rogen replied to it
he's like why are you why are you upset
LA's one of the best cities on Earth you
just have to know if you park your car
outside you're going to get broken into
my car is broken into 15 times they even
left me a treat one time so he's like
he's like and he was fully serious he
was 100 serious it was the worst [ __ ]
tweet I've ever read I love that dreams
out of touch celebrity Twitter oh my God
oh my gosh actually one question I've
always wanted to ask you is uh
concerning YouTube right so your lack of
thumbnails is that like is that by
choice yeah and I just don't give it a
lot of thought and I don't stretch them
on purpose for what it's worth yeah
some of the ones I see and I'm like that
has to be like a Photoshop edit no it's
never so I I use Sony Vegas any Sony
Vegas oh yeah yeah you see you see that
we're terrible we are terrible we are
inferior
listen this is why I don't edit my
videos it's like Sony Vegas I don't know
how to end so in Sony Vegas you'll know
when you put in an image sometimes it
gets those black bars on the side you
just stretch
I click stretch it and then a screenshot
I click uh I untick maintain aspect
ratio it stretches it for me and then I
save the screenshot
ten percent more effort than prosies
he told us that he just picks one of the
three I used to do that I used to but
yeah I stopped because now for some
reason YouTube's really fixated on those
Auto generated thumbnails on the goofy
[ __ ] like when my eyes are closed it's
like he's like yeah [ __ ] it I'll do it
no he's got
he's great yeah he's awesome yeah I love
the whole low after thumbnail thing I
love it so much it's really cool I just
shot doing that important in Sony Vegas
yeah I would say just untick maintain
aspect ratio you'll see the light you'll
be like wow
okay so what are you putting in that the
video or like a screenshot so I'll just
take like a screenshot of the video but
it takes those black bars on the side so
yeah bring it in and
untick the end why can't you just open
up the video in like VLC and just
screenshot makes no sense now you're
speaking huh he doesn't even know Sunny
Vegas works
even if it's a [ __ ] like vertical
phone video you just like [ __ ] blow
yeah
like [ __ ] yeah we're gonna look at your
Channel right now
foreign
video still sometimes all of them that
aren't like the bigger projects yeah so
just the ones of you in your room
talking about something damn it's really
not much work
the fact that you can just commit to
that and do it yeah and the fact that
you upload 60 videos a month as well
like if it was like once a week then I'd
be like yeah okay not much extra effort
right but you're doing it like almost
every day and it's pretty quick though
you just it's like what you guys do with
the you know podcast you just talk just
talk at a camera and then like the
editing's pretty simple you just cut
like you just put the things together
for me that's what I do like if it's
just talking I just splice it and then I
mean if you ask me to edit this podcast
I'll be like [ __ ] that well I guess it's
harder because you have to sync
everyone's audio and everything right
yeah whenever you say anything he throws
it off yeah awful and we have like the
whole time stamps and everything he does
that it is a beast yeah absolutely thank
you very much episode 100 will be
thanking me down for keeping this
podcast
I'm glad you still use Sony Vegas I'm
one of the still I'm few people I know a
few YouTubers who still use Sony Vegas
there's four of us now it's the three of
us and then tough tough makes a lot of
like dark content like surrounding like
you know twitch moments or stalkers and
stuff like that we have four Sony Vegas
users
I feel the Fisher Price of editing
something yeah it is okay it
legitimately is like it is it is
designed for literal like 10 years it's
like none of the stuff makes sense
professionally but if you're literally
doing the bare minimum it's the easiest
do you want to be a YouTuber you must
face the Elite Four yeah yeah
when you're starting out it is really
easy to get it it's so easy I feel so
bad because I do actually like higher
edited sometimes right and obviously
they use [ __ ] like Premiere Pro yeah
because they're relatives and I feel bad
because I still have like a hand in the
editing process so what I'll do is I'll
get them to render out the video and
render out the audio separately and then
I re-edited so many people oh my God I
editing is not fun it's just not it
simply isn't it can be fun if you have
like a actual good editing project well
like if it's
I'd say if it's not you directly like if
you're editing your own thing I feel
like it's just oh [ __ ] it's just not
fashion oh yeah it's just I do it it's
done yeah yeah yeah it's quick it's easy
yeah I definitely see like it being fun
for like a bigger project if you've got
like some project that you're like have
a hand in yeah it's much better yeah
yeah what I like is like having like big
fun projects and I get my editing team
to do like the bulk of the work I do
like the fun little bit so I enjoy the
creative expression yeah yeah exactly
yeah right right yeah the moment I could
have I I was able to afford an editor I
was like I'll go broke I do not want to
do this it's just not fun I would it
would make videos that should have been
like two days like two weeks because I
would just procrastinate I'd be like
I'll play another game of League I did I
did one like chroma key or one key frame
that's it that's the day awful stuff
what games are you into now
it's a lot better so they took out a
player so it's 5v5 yeah one less tank
yeah and that changed everything so the
game's like actually fun now can they
come back after all the controversy they
had I don't I don't think it'll ever be
an esport again like I think the Esports
scene I think is [ __ ] like there's
really I don't think there's much they
can do this appeal to the porn Community
I think that's the way it's huge the
porn Community is massive I feel like if
they just catered towards that just keep
giving them characters they can make
porn off I think it'll say around I
think that's the problem they started
making robots and [ __ ] and it was not
doing it for like yeah that's when near
automatic dinner right yeah yeah I mean
some of the most talented 3D artists and
animators I don't know are all doing
[ __ ] porn
it's insane how good it looks man
Widowmaker and diva porn was like better
than anything pixel ever put out like it
was shocking everything from that
Community is on another level of
equality
it's like the Pentagon comes together to
like bring all their processing power to
make 20 second Loop of Widowmaker
getting raped like it's insane and let's
not forget Tifa is now officially part
of Italian law yeah right yeah
legendary that's so good just one of my
favorite meme videos I saw recently was
just like the history of it of Italy and
it's just like the entire like a quick
like uh PNG of like the entire history
of Italy then there's one frame of teeth
and that's just just perfectly
encapsulated oh my gosh I mean if any
country's gonna do it it's probably
Italy they had like a prime minister
like I don't know like two prime
ministers ago that would openly talk
about having orgies and stuff was that
Italy I know who you're talking about
I'm thinking you're talking about having
orgies all the time he's like 70. he's
[ __ ] he was insane dude he I don't know
why Italians loved him like he would
talk about orgies and he was like yeah
dude what an alpha male I'm [ __ ]
voting for that guy he was in this guy
is insane like you hear him talking like
this is this is not someone who should
be running this guy should be managing
at Danny's at best like this is this is
not prime minister material Italian Hugh
Hefner running the [ __ ] country
because that's what that's the top of
Italian priority like [ __ ] it like
everything else is second like maybe
like pasta or something yeah
the economy
no not even dude not even